(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are asking and potentially answering
100% airtight--
- Okay.
- Answer to the question can
we be friends with robots?
Will it happen?
- And the reason we ask this
is because we were recently
approached by a robot.
- We were propositioned for friendship.
- Yeah, propositioned just for friendship.
- By an android.
- And so we decided we
would just explore that
in the context of an Ear Biscuit.
- Because there's this general assumption
that with the development of
AI that it's going to happen
but then you start digging
into the specifics of it
and I just don't know,
I don't really know, so
it's a legitimate question
on my mind, I don't have a
specific answer, you know me.
I just wanna verbally process it out
but come to an airtight conclusion.
- Having not thought about it very much--
- Okay.
- I have an answer.
- You have an answer?
- But I'm gonna hold it until the end
and see if it still holds.
- All right and my objective
would be to change your answer
so that by the end--
- But you don't know what my answer is.
- I know and then, you
should write it down,
'cause my objective is
to change your answer
no matter what it is.
It's like extreme devil's advocate.
- Just so you know a
little, peeling it back,
pulling back the curtain a little bit.
- Open the kimono.
- The previous podcasts
we recorded two days ago.
This is two days later, this is 48 hours
further into my cold cycle
and I've actually been going into,
I've been going on the internet and--
- Oh gosh of course you have.
- No the thing is--
- Well what are you
convinced you have, what type of cancer?
- No, the thing that I was
interested in is I was like
does the progression of a cold, meaning--
- Lead to death.
- The symptoms.
No I'm not worried about
my life at this point.
I know that this is just a regular cold,
but do the symptoms of a cold,
is the progression the same for everyone?
'Cause I would have said
no, my colds always start
with a so and so.
My colds always start with a so and so.
(Link chuckles)
You know,
it's like the Muppets.
I just did all the Muppet voices.
- Were you on SesameStreet.com
asking about colds?
- And then so, I wanna ask you,
'cause you're just a layman, right,
you haven't been on the internet looking
at this specific information.
- I'll take it.
- So what do you think
the typical progression
of a cold is and then what do
you think the average length
of a cold is and what happens
in those certain days.
Just throw out some facts.
- And if I am considered to be a layman,
I'll take that as a
compliment if that means
that I rely on my own
experience and intellect
and intuition versus
leaning way too heavily on--
- Science?
- What's beyond my keyboard.
- Okay, yeah.
- I go on feels, man.
I'm going completely on feels here.
I think that's part of
our codependence Rhett,
is that I just assume
you're gonna at least take
the stance that you know it so
I'm not gonna waste my time.
- The reason--
- But I will answer
your question.
- But the reason
I looked it up was because,
48 hours from right now,
we will be on stage
rehearsing, doing a soundcheck,
getting ready to then perform a concert
and so I was looking, I was
like, I wanna kinda know
where I'm gonna be, I wanna
be able to mentally prepare
and that led into this whole like
well this is the life cycle of a cold
and this is what the symptoms are
and this when, it's all typical.
So what do you think that is?
- What's the first question?
The life cycle, how long does it last?
- Just in any part of--
- I would say a typical
cold virus runs its course
in five days.
It's more than that?
- And you know what, I
believe that the perception
of an individual is that
it's about five days.
Seven to 10 days.
- Okay but that includes like
a ramp up and a ramp down
where you think you're better--
- That's the full cycle.
- And you don't know
you have it--
- The full cycle.
- Okay and what's the other question?
- What's the first symptom,
what's the second symptom?
- And is it the same for everyone?
- Right.
- No I believe that,
I mean--
- What is it with you
when it happens?
- Well enough has gone
through our family that,
certain family members,
they'll complain about headaches
and a really bad sore
throat and then I'll get it
and I might have the headache
but I don't have the sore throat
but I'll have a different,
slightly different symptoms
but I have to assume
that it just went around the house.
- Yeah they're never a
complete, even for me,
never completely the same but I would say
on average there's an initial symptom
and then there's, yeah.
I have an initial symptom most often.
- But what did Sesame Street say?
- It said that, well,
it listed a collection
of symptoms that a lot
of times are the onset
but the sore throat is always
in that initial set of symptoms.
Like you don't end your
cold with a sore throat,
right, you usually start
your cold with a sore throat.
For me--
- Sometimes I'll never have
a sore throat but I guess
that's just a really mild cold
but so your answer is that there is like
a viral protocol of symptoms
that everyone goes through.
- Well in general, yeah, and so for me--
- So the same cold does
not manifest itself
differently in different people.
- Well--
- According to your--
- No, it just said this is all typical
so I'm not making blanket statements about
it wouldn't affect a person differently.
I'm just saying that I would
have said before I looked
at this article that I typically
start with a sore throat
and then I start doing all the
stuff that you're supposed,
you know, taking Zicam and
zinc, whatever I've got.
If we got Cold-Eeze or Zicam,
some sort of zinc thing.
You start to get hydrated, vitamin C.
- Googling obsessively.
- And then I'd say seven out of 10 times,
the sore throat recedes
and nothing happens.
It does not become a
full-blown cold, right?
Whether that's the stuff
that I did to prevent it
or whether it's just my body
fought it off, I don't know.
- Okay.
- If the sore throat gets really intense
and this is what happened with this one,
then I'm like, I don't think
I'm coming back from this one.
If it becomes really difficult to swallow
and you're like oh no.
- You have to go
through the tunnel, you can't turn back.
- And then the next--
- Or exit through
the entrance.
- Then the next symptom
is it moves to the nose.
And that's when--
- Cloggage.
- The stuffiness,
the runniness, so, and
then it said the peak,
when the virus is as spread as it can be
throughout your body, it's the
peak activity of the virus,
you are your most contagious
is when your face,
it said your face may feel like a faucet
which is exactly the way I described it.
- So when I was shoulder to
shoulder with you all day
the day before yesterday.
- I was at peak contagion.
- Dang it and then you laid out yesterday.
You should have laid out
day before yesterday.
- I had too much to do.
- You laid out too late.
We could have shifted the
stuff from two days ago,
I don't know how that works, you know,
we have shifters and schedulers and--
- Yeah so I basically just
rested all day yesterday.
- Jacob's shaking his head like
that's how you think of me?
A shifter and a scheduler?
(Rhett chuckles)
Yeah when you're not around
I just, I call you shifter.
Just get that bearded
shifter to schedule it up.
- Know that this is not coming from me.
- Well you know I'm joking,
I don't call you that.
I call you Jacob, even
when you're not around.
That's all I've ever called you.
- And then--
- No nicknames.
- And then okay oh first of all--
- Shifter, I never--
- Initial symptoms--
- Now I feel like
my nose is running.
- One to three days.
One to three days.
Peak cold symptoms days four to seven.
- Oh gosh.
- And then tail end
of the cold is days eight to 10.
Again this is all typical.
- You sabotaged our show, man.
So by the time you're listening to this,
we're back from the show.
- I don't think you're
gonna get sick, man,
because that's not an initial symptom.
That's just psychosomatic.
You have a sore throat?
- No.
- Good, you're fine.
- Maybe I had a tinge right then.
(chuckles)
- But then--
- You're literally rubbing off
on me, I'm not only emotionally
gettin' wigged out--
- Hold on but this is not--
- But you're physically
rubbing off on me.
- Hold on but this is not
hypochondriacism if that's a word.
- For me it now is.
- That's not what I'm talking about.
I'm just saying this is what
I learned in my research.
But the last--
- You stay in bed all day?
Just researching?
- Which is really, really
hard to do by the way.
It's hard to make
yourself go back to sleep.
- I haven't done that since the vasectomy.
Well no I've been sick a
few times but I didn't,
it was over the weekend.
- I ended up doing some work from the bed.
- Christy gets mad 'cause
she's like why do you always
get sick on the weekend?
You're like I gotta stay in bed all day.
Like well, I understand that's frustrating
but that's just how it's happened.
I think my body knows that it can relax
and the white blood cells
just take the weekend off
or something.
- Yeah, there's a lot of that.
I know there's a lot of mental,
I haven't gotten sick
at all this entire year
and it was just like my body was just like
all right you need to get,
you need to do it, you
need to get it done,
you need to get it in
and get it over with.
(chuckles)
- Kinda like a dentist
appointment or something.
- Is that the tail end
of the cold is when,
like I'm probably day seven
right now so it's like receding,
my nose is still stuffed
up but it's not running
and then a lot of times it
will transition into a cough
which is a little worrying
if I've got a cough
while we're trying to sing
but I think I'll be okay.
But then you know that you can,
and this is totally normal.
You know you have a lingering cough
after a cold a lot of times.
- Mm-hmm.
- They say that it is
not unusual for the cough
to last 18 days after the cold
and that is not a concern.
It doesn't mean you have an infection,
it doesn't mean it's gone anywhere else,
it's just you can have an 18 day cold.
- Are you contagious?
You're not contagious either?
I mean that's my main concern.
I'm talking about me, for me.
- No you're not contagious.
- No, are you contagious?
- Right now?
- Yeah to me.
- Not nearly as much
as I was two days ago.
- Gosh.
- You got through the worst of it.
- So we packed our stuff,
we're going on this trip.
By the time you listen to
this, we'll be back from it.
But hey, and I was gonna
say follow us on Instagram
'cause I intend on posting some stories.
Shout out to LinkLamont on Instagram.
- Yup.
- But those stories
will have dissipated.
Maybe not.
- But if you archive them,
if you make them a highlight.
You know how to do that?
- I haven't done that yet.
I haven't done one so now I'm like,
I'm nervous to make one.
- You just gotta do it.
- Just gotta do it.
And I'll do that.
- Make a highlight.
- So if you're listening to
this and it's even dissipated,
you can still go back and see the,
Britton's very excited,
he's comin' in later,
he's going with us.
- See if I can get him sick.
- Well, don't.
I think he and I are sharing hotel rooms.
- Oh good.
- Just for efficiency sake.
- That's good, I hadn't
thought about that.
- I don't think we had
to do that honestly,
but you know how I think.
I'm just like let's bring Britton along.
He can stay in my room.
(Rhett laughs)
We could have given the guy his own room
and I could have kept, had my own room.
- Yeah that's the thing,
by giving him his--
- Aren't we to that point?
- By giving him his own room,
you therefore get your own room.
Did you not think about that?
- All I that about was
just the efficiency of it.
I think it'll be fun, we'll
have a slumber party one night.
- The best part of traveling
is having my own hotel room.
I mean that's the only reason I tour.
- What's the best part of wakin' up?
- Folgers, of course.
- In your cup.
- But I mean--
- Folgers in your cup.
- Folgers in every hotel room.
- Yeah, Folgers is not a sponsor
because their coffee is horrible.
I wouldn't even call it horrible.
- Hold on but what if they
wanted to be a sponsor?
- No 'cause it's horrible.
I could never be sponsored by Folgers.
- I bet you I could make
you like Folgers, man.
I bet you I could sneak Folgers in to--
- That's a GMM.
- I think it was a GMM.
(both laugh)
That's the thing, I think we've done--
- Well we forgot, let's do it again.
- I think we did a coffee taste test
and I wonder what we said about Folgers.
- So you roll in this
morning, I texted you.
What did I text you this morning?
- You text me this morning?
- I texted you this morning.
What, don't you remember?
It was only this morning.
- I thought you texted me last night.
- No.
Was that last night?
- It was last night at 8:38.
- Oh yeah last night.
What did I text you last night?
- You said, "How are you feeling?
"I think I am checking a luggage."
(both chuckle)
Checking a luggage.
- Well I asked how you were feeling first
but my main objective as you can tell was,
now that I'm concerned
that I'm checking a bag,
I wanna make sure you are but I need
to ask how you're feeling first.
- Why you gotta worry
about me checking a bag?
'Cause you don't wanna be
the only guy checking a bag?
- I didn't want you to be shaming me,
I didn't wanna slow down the
whole transportation process
and then, 'cause I know how
it would be, it's like man,
I'm not checking a bag--
- No hold on--
- And then the whole time
we're checking my bag you're
like I'm not checking a bag.
- But hold on, I don't do that.
- I'm not saying you do it, I
just don't want you to do it.
- No no that's not in
my personality profile.
I don't pick on other people's decisions.
I don't do that, that's not my thing.
- But you get so nervous
when we're checking
into a hotel, you're telling me that
that wouldn't put you over the edge?
I'm not saying you constantly--
- No, you mean checking into--
- I just feel like
I put a target on my back.
- You mean the airline, you
mean getting on the plane.
- Checking in.
- You said checking
into the hotel, I was like, I don't--
- Not the hotel, the airport.
- I don't have a lot of,
there's no stress once
we're checking into the hotel.
- The airport.
- Yeah I mean but
I don't get stressed out
when we travel because--
- And then what did you say?
- We make, I get stressed out
when I travel with my family.
I don't get stressed out
when I travel with us
because we always, it's
scheduled correctly.
- Okay yeah yeah, but--
- We leave on time.
It's all scheduled ahead of time.
- I'm glad we're having this conversation
because when I'm checkin' my luggage.
And apparently you're not,
I mean what did you say?
Your response was, "I'm feeling better.
"I think I'll be even better tomorrow."
I was like great but then
as far as the luggage goes,
I don't think you responded.
- 'Cause I didn't have an opinion.
'Cause I don't, 'cause again, it's great.
- Okay.
- You want me to
compliment you on it?
- No I just felt--
- You wanted to hear if I was
gonna check a luggage as well?
- Yeah.
- Well first of all,
I didn't know at the time
but I didn't have plans to,
but I also was like, you can
check luggage, I don't care.
Check a luggage.
The one thing I almost did was make fun
of the way you said it
which is I will do that
in a heartbeat.
- I don't know why--
- I'll make fun of the way somebody
says something in a heartbeat.
- I wrote, I was gonna write check a bag
and when I wrote the a, then
I was like, you know what,
I'm gonna use the word luggage.
But I didn't delete the word a.
I didn't delete the a so
it became a check a luggage
but it was supposed to be
check a bag or check luggage.
- The only reason I'm not
checking a luggage is because
my backpack is, what is it, the Tortoise,
I don't know what it is, it's very big.
It's a suitcase in
and of itself.
- It's too big actually.
I don't know, do you like that?
It's too big.
- I love it.
- It's too big to carry
something like that around.
- No because now I don't
have to check a luggage.
- And you know what the
other thing I realized
was there was a type of
product that has gone the way
of the dodo and that is a--
- The suitcases that you
had to pull on a string?
- That, the suitcases
that have a laptop slot.
They don't, those are, they're going out.
Nobody wants those because
everybody bought 'em
including us and then what do you do?
You end up packing your
stuff on a carry on
but you keep your laptop in
the bag that it's always in
and then you use that
as like your backpack,
your additional bag.
You don't leave your computer bag at home,
take the computer out and
put it in your carry on
because what about all the
other crap that you need
every single day that's
in your laptop bag?
- Well, I do exactly what
you just said you don't do.
I put it into a backpack that has its,
I put it into a backpack.
- A bigger backpack.
- That has a bunch of stuff.
We travel a lot.
That backpack is, the only--
- I think you're doing it,
I think your approach is subpar.
- No, you bring--
- And I know this is ironic
that I'm the one judging you now but--
- You bring a regular backpack on a trip
and I'll do that if it's a short trip
but if I need some stuff to be packed
and I don't wanna check anything,
I put it in that big bag.
- Why don't you wanna check anything?
I'm checking something.
See I'm interpreting that as judgment.
- I'm saying--
- You must think it's better
to not check something.
- Well first of all, I prefer
to travel with my big backpack
because it has other things.
There's a bunch of pockets in there
that have like hand
sanitizer and moisturizer
and sunscreen and all kinds of things
that are just in there
always that I don't have
in my regular backpack and so I know
that all I gotta do is
put my laptop in there.
In fact, for awhile there I
had a completely duplicate set
of chargers for all my stuff--
- Oh wow.
- That I never had to take out
of that backpack.
Of course I've got children
and so they've taken them.
- Yeah, they're gone.
- But so now I just take it out of my,
I just take the little
coil of laptop charger,
phone charger, watch charger
and I just move it over
and then I, it's that simple, man.
- See.
- I've taken books.
I got a big book.
- Okay.
- My wife bought me a novel by a guy named
James A. McLaughlin and she just bought it
because his name was McLaughlin, Bearskin.
I'm gonna read that.
- Okay.
- It's got a cool, it's
huge, it's a hard back.
Where am I gonna put that?
I gotta have a big bag for that.
- See I think if I had a big bag,
what you're saying is
really appealing to me,
like having everything on my back.
- You also should have your
own thing of toiletries
ready to go.
Don't duplicate your own toiletries.
- I would constantly, I
would come back from a trip
and I would carry that around forever
because my laptop bag basically
has all that stuff in it.
Hand balm, hand sanitizer,
multiple headphones, chargers,
all that stuff is there anyway.
For my, every day I travel.
Every time I move I'm traveling.
- Technically true.
- So that's what I do but then
I also pack a frickin' big
piece of luggage that I gotta check
that has everything including a pillow.
Giving the upcoming up of GMM that we're--
- Hold on you're packing a
pillow for use not on the plane
but in the hotel room.
- Yes.
- Man.
You shouldn't listen that
hard to that info, man.
It's not that big of--
- It also gives me
a much higher quality
sleep because my sleep
is so dependent on my pillow.
- That's a personal problem.
- No it's just know thyself man.
I'm winning on two fronts,
hygiene and posture,
like neck posture, good night's sleep.
It's the start of everything.
So anyway, I'm now checking some luggage.
- I just like to adapt to
different pillow configurations
just in case I have to
be, during the apocalypse,
I'm gonna be sleeping
on dirt and just twigs
and you know, I'm gonna have
a bag full of human bones
that I'm sleeping on.
- At the end of your life,
I think as you're dying
and I'm leaning over your wilting body,
I don't know what's the last
thing you're gonna say is
but I think the last thing
I'm gonna say to you is,
I'm just gonna lean in real
close and I'm gonna say,
"The apocalypse never happened."
- Yeah but I was ready in case it did.
- You worked so hard.
It's a transactional decision for me.
It's very wise and I know
it will make me feel good
to be prepped like you are but I just,
I also feel like--
(sighs)
I just feel like--
- Well here's the thing.
It's not about being prepped.
- It's a lot of wasted life.
- My honest opinion on
the pillow situation is--
- And that episode comes
out tomorrow in reference
to when this comes out, by the way,
so the housekeeping and what
they clean or don't clean
in your hotel, it's
impacting my personal life.
I'm bringing my freakin' pillow.
- You may have a better
sleeping experience--
- On the bus too, man.
- Compared to what
you would have had.
- You remember the pillow
on the bus, the tour bus?
Me neither, I don't even
know if there was one.
- But here's what I'm saying.
In the long run, if you
make yourself dependent
on the pillow, there's
gonna be more scenarios
in which you just can't bring your pillow.
There's gonna be times where,
the next time we travel,
you'll be like, I'm
not checking a luggage.
- Listen, I'm already
dependent on my pillow,
so whenever I can have
it, I'm gonna have it,
and then when I don't, it will
be less amount of suffering
than if I never brought it
'cause I'm not gonna train myself
to not need the pillow, forget about it.
- You should be like Jim Aycock
and just sleep with no pillow.
Do you know that's what he did?
- 102 years old and he golfs every day.
- Yeah.
- Sleeps with no pillow.
- And he will tell you that's
one of the keys to life.
(Link sputters)
Sleeping with no pillow.
- Here's the thing with
people who are really old.
They all think they have a key to life
and it's the genes, man.
It's nothing it's like my
key to life is I eat bacon
and ice cream every day and I'm 102.
No.
That's just you thumbing your nose at us
at the rest of the gene pool.
Don't take credit for that
and don't give the credit
to bacon and ice cream.
- But sleeping without a
pillow, that's pretty badass.
- Pillah.
- Let's talk about--
- With a pillah.
- Let's talk about robots.
But first we wanna let you know
that you can purchase Link's hat.
- Give me a quick body scan to see
if I had on any other merch.
No just the hat.
- That is the thing
that we're promoting, right, the camo--
- Yeah.
- The camo GMM hat.
- There it is, it's nice, man.
It's got the GMM logo in camo.
- Does it say Mythical on the inside?
- No it doesn't.
It doesn't need to.
- I think that might be the prototype.
I think the one that you buy does.
- Oh gosh.
- I'm not making any promises, but--
- You know what the best ads are?
The ones where you talk about
what's wrong with the product.
How the product is lacking.
- Who cares what it says on the inside?
(Link chuckles)
It's camo.
- Rep your boys.
Go to Mythical.store.
I like wearing hats when I
travel so I got this one,
I got the black Post-Apawcalypse dog hat
which is one of my favorites.
I highly recommend that.
There's always the bandana
from when I work out
from the road.
That's right, I'm gonna
work out from the road.
- Let's save that for, let's save,
that could be a whole
intro to an Ear Biscuit
in and of itself, we
should talk about that.
- Yeah, hopefully it comes to fruition.
Mythical.store.
Thank you for being your
Mythical best which,
I'm not gonna equate that
to spending money on us.
So I'll take that back, just
thank you for buying merch.
I think everybody wins.
I'm proud of the merch.
- Okay let's talk about friendship.
With robots.
- So Feldman brought to our
attention a Medium article
by Evan Selinger called Can
We Be Friends With Robots
and I think he pitched
it because friendship,
friendship's a thing for us, you know?
We're friends.
- Right.
- It's been happenin' for a long time.
Are we experts in friendship?
I don't know, on one hand
I feel like we're experts
at our friendship, on the other hand,
I feel like there's
still so much to explore
that I actually don't know
if we're experts at our own friendship.
- I would definitely say I'm
not an expert at friendship.
- At our friendship, like just--
- Yeah.
- Understanding it.
So let's, I'm interested
in filtering our feelings
about our capacity to have
true friendship with a robot.
Maybe through our experience
in our own friendship.
I think there are some
parallels, so spoiler alert.
A little background though.
In his article, and in a
few others that I read,
they mention the way that
Aristotle talked about friendship
and he actually, you
know who Aristotle is?
- I've heard of him.
- He's a philosopher.
He talked about three
different types of friendships.
Utility friendships which are basically,
some examples are like
business partnerships,
alliances, like a Survivor alliance.
Speak the parlance of reality television.
A friendship where you, you
know, you get something out
of it that otherwise you wouldn't get.
- I call those transactional
friendships and I think--
- Yeah you can improve on Aristotle.
- I think that 90% or
more of relationships
in Los Angeles are transactional.
- Yeah.
What can you give me life access to?
- How can I,
a second Aristotle friendship
is friendships of pleasure.
- Hmm.
- Ooh.
Activity buddies, you know.
Hey, let's do a sport.
Let's do a hobby.
Let's build a Popsicle stick castle.
- We did that once.
With the RAs.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The Royal Ambassadors.
- Yeah they had this
whole room and you'd just go in there
and you'd just keep adding
to the Popsicle stick fort.
Pretty cool.
- And then we would go
in there after that and
at least I would go in
and rip it apart a little bit.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Did you notice how every once in awhile
you'd go in there and it would be like
oh another part had fallen.
- Yeah it was like they're lettin'
the pre-schoolers in here.
Why are they lettin'
the younger kids in here
when nobody, keep an
eye on the younger kids.
- It was me.
- They keep coming in.
(chuckles)
So yeah.
- I was slowly
destroying our creation.
- That's when it's, hey,
we just have fun together.
It's all about doing.
I think in general, guys
in my limited observation,
are more willingly settle
in or settle for this type
of friendship, that's just like hey,
we could shoot the breeze,
we could grab a brewski
or we can hike a mountain
or we can play tag football,
or again, Popsicle sticks.
And that's good enough.
But Aristotle talks about
a third type of friendship
called friendship of the good which is,
perhaps a more complete friendship I think
it could be described as,
it's based on mutual goodwill
and unselfish desire to help
the other person become his
or her best possible self.
So there's a selfless component
and like a legitimate care for somebody.
There's some buddy love.
- Mm.
- Now...
I think we can filter
the robot conversation
as we delve into it through that.
- Well first of all, I
think that it's easy,
it's easy to see that robots
fall, without a doubt fall
into category one.
Friendships of utility.
Because when we think about
robots, we think about,
what was the one from The Jetsons?
- The maid, Rosie.
- Rosie?
You know, Rosie's the maid.
She's doing something and of course,
you may have a relationship
but the relationship is
in the context of what
Rosie can do for you
so without a doubt that those
types of friendships exist.
- But interesting that--
- Can exist.
- I think they demonstrated very well
because I just bought
it hook line and sinker
that she was a member of the family.
But she's a member of the
family created specifically
to just clean up after
'em and like, you know,
I never saw Astro's poop anywhere
now that I think about it.
- Can't show poop on cartoon television.
- That's bull crap, man.
Well it's Astro crap.
- Can't show it, it's a rule.
- I actually think they could show it
but Rosie was so good at her job
that it was never there for
more than a split second,
like she had an innate ability.
Her artificial intelligence was honed.
But I considered her a
member of the family.
I mean Elroy certainly loved her.
- Well of course, I mean--
- So I do think it is a form of friendship
because as you talked about
the transactional nature,
it tends to cheapen it so
much that I actually question
can you even call that friendship?
Are you friends with Alexa?
- Not Alexa.
- No.
Or the Google Siri person.
- The Google Siri
person, that's confusing.
- It's two different people, right?
- Right.
- Google doesn't have a name.
They just call it Google.
- Right.
- Which I prefer.
Because it sets a strong boundary.
It's not like I'm pretending that this,
I don't have to call it a human name.
- And that's an interesting
thing 'cause one
of the articles I was reading
was the difference between,
if you contrast sort of western approaches
to sort of embodied AI
to the way they see it
in Japan, for instance.
You just sort of, I
don't know exactly where
that's coming from and
you're like I feel like
there needs to be a boundary.
- Mm-hmm.
- But that boundary
does not exist in Japan, the
way they've embraced robots
and the personality of robots, in fact,
Sony's, I think it's AIBO.
Is that the dog robot?
When one of those robots in Japan,
those robots are so revered in Japan
that when you can no longer repair them,
they have like a funeral for the dog.
- Really?
- Yeah.
Yeah, AIBO.
- A-I-B-O.
- And that's something
that we're like what?
Like typically I think the way that we,
and I don't know which
one, we had that robot dog
on the show at one point.
I don't know if that's the same one.
I can't imagine that dog,
'cause the way that would go
at my house, because I
think we actually had that.
- You can't converse with
that dog we had on the show.
- Well you can't converse with a dog.
They speak dog anyway.
So I think this dog just does dog things.
- Yes you can, you can say sit to a dog.
- Right, well I think you can say,
regardless of whether this is
the one that I've seen before,
the way it would go at
the McLaughlin household
is we would have thing and
everybody would think it was cool
for like 48 hours and then
there would be like two months
of every other day somebody
would do something with it
and then it would be put in a closet
and then it would be forgotten about
and then it would be
thrown away or Craigslisted
or yard saled.
- But if Siri--
- Yard sold.
- Or Alexa could be
moved into a mobile body,
let's not say it looks like a human
but let's just say it's more android.
It's a little more personified.
So we're not venturing
into the uncanny valley
with some weirdness but it's just like,
like a Rosie situation.
- Yeah.
- I think psychologically,
you would start to form bonds.
I mean, even--
- Of course you would.
- Even when Lando goes to sleep he's like,
okay Google, tell me a bedtime story.
And she, it, whatever, will
tell a bedtime story sometimes.
Well, every single time he
asks without fail, actually.
- A different one?
- Yeah a different one.
- For how long do the stories go?
- Maybe eight minutes.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Interesting.
- I mean he doesn't do,
he doesn't do it every night
but if okay Google walked up,
like strutted over, did a
little hammer dance over
to the bed side and then told the story,
all of a sudden, he's forming
a bond with this person.
And that moves to the second one--
- Are you, you said the bond.
You seem to be, I'm just
saying, I'm picking up
on some suspicion on
whether or not this bond
would be a good thing or not.
- I felt weird, it feels
weirder to me to say Alexa
than it does to say okay Google.
- But why?
- Because it's, I know I'm
not talking to a person.
I'm talking to a speaker.
So it seems kinda stupid.
It's like if I have friends over,
I feel like a douche if
I'm like okay Google,
turn on all the lights.
But I feel like more of
a douche if I'm like,
Alexa, turn on the lights.
It's like, it's even
worse because it's like--
- I don't see that distinction.
- I'm talking to a speaker
but I called it a human name.
- You're not talking to a speaker.
The speaker is just the physical form.
You're talking to the AI.
- I would feel less, I think
I would feel more comfortable
if it was a moving, emotive robot.
- Oh so you would be more comfortable--
- Yes.
- If it was more human-like.
- Yeah 'cause it's not physically there.
It's like who am I fooling?
But I also know that you can
quickly get to that point,
like, but back to the Aristotle of it all,
I think that the second, you
said that utility friendships,
robots definitely fall into
that category now but also--
- I'm just saying,
I'm not putting them in a category,
I'm saying we already know they can attain
that level of friendship.
- Right,
they can also attain--
- I'm not speaking
to the next two.
- The next one,
friendships of pleasure.
I think--
- A pleasure robot.
- Well there's sex bots of course.
- Yeah.
- Let's just get that
out of the way.
That's not what we're discussing.
- Oh we're not?
- But--
- That's what I was
looking forward to.
- But--
(chuckles)
I mean, I think that
that checks that box, the second box.
I don't mean to keep saying the word box.
- Yep.
- But to bring it back into
just the normal household realm.
I mean Lando also plays Mad Libs.
So he's gettin' bedtime stories,
he plays Mad Libs with Google.
There's different games you can play
so there's like, you
know, there's pleasure.
So there's hobbies.
- Yeah without a doubt.
- Activity buddies.
So there you go, you got that second one
where it's just like oh we're hanging out
and I'm playing with this
speaker in the same way
that I would play with another person.
- Well I think that the human
tendency is to personify
things that don't even have
any human characteristics.
- Oh yeah.
- The classic example
being Wiltson, you know what I'm saying,
a volleyball becomes a companion.
- There's no T in it but I'm with you.
- Wilson.
- Wilson is not, just
like if you say Clempson,
it's not an incorrect pronunciation.
- Okay.
- If you go to
the Wilson Headquarters, I
guarantee you somebody there,
maybe the president, says Wiltson.
He doesn't say Wilson because Wilson
makes you sound like a douche.
- Let's look into that.
Later.
Oh and trees.
- And trees.
- Trees.
That's another example.
You ever looked at a tree and you're like
look at the bark of that tree.
It looks like there's two
eyes and a smiling face.
- That's not what I'm talking about.
- That tree is more, that tree--
- No no but what
I'm talking about--
- Can talk to me.
- I'm talking about in the
case of the volleyball,
because humans need relationship,
they will create relationship from things
that don't offer anything
because they need
some kind of interaction so--
- Yes.
- Your natural tendency
is to develop a bond with
whatever there is available
to develop a bond with.
In fact so there was another
article I was reading
which was,
there was this robot that,
it was like 100 people
that they sat down with this robot
and they thought that
they were doing some kind
of experiment based on the questions
that the robot was asking.
- Mm-hmm.
- But the real experiment was--
(clears throat)
At the end of the question
and answer period,
the robot, they say at
the end of the thing,
now cut the robot off.
Now turn the robot off.
And at the end of the last question,
instead of, if the robot starts saying,
"No, don't turn me off!"
(chuckles)
"Please, no, I'm scared of the dark.
"Don't turn the lights off
and don't turn me off."
The robot begins to beg
to not be turned off--
- Oh wow.
- And--
- People didn't do it.
- Of course--
- People stopped.
- This impacted people.
Some people, like a quarter of
the people refused to turn--
- Okay still the minority--
- To turn off the robot at all
and then the vast majority
took twice as long
to turn the robot off from the people who,
the robot didn't beg.
So--
- Oh gosh.
What do you think you would have done?
- I probably would have
turned him off laughing.
But--
- Yeah, laugh.
- Just because that's
the kind of person I am
but that doesn't mean I wouldn't
have felt a little bit bad.
Because--
- Right.
I think I would have laughed too
and I would have thought
it was like a prank video.
- Well because there's,
the things that, the way that
you are processing information
from anything that, any
sort of being or any object,
it doesn't really, the nature of,
as long as that thing
like checks a few boxes
like you were saying, it's gonna affect us
and it's gonna connect with
us in a way that a human does.
For instance, without
a doubt if you're able
to get all the way to the
point where you can essentially
make a robot indistinguishable
from a human,
well at that point, the
nature of the relationship
will be indistinguishable
from the relationship
that you could have with a human,
even if that person,
depending on where you're at
in terms of your world
view and what you think
about spirituality and soul or whatever,
even if this particular thing doesn't have
a quote unquote soul, if
that's your world view,
the nature or your
relationship with it would be
indistinguishable from a
relationship with a regular person.
- So we are moving to that third stage of,
friendship the good complete.
I mean, when you have an
unselfish exchange of care
in a relationship so it's
like there's empathy,
there's emotion, there's
a responsiveness that...
AI is being developed to do that.
Do we actually feel like
it could go all the way?
And I think that you
make a good point that,
it's just as much about
humans as it is about
the capability of technology
and what humans can do
on that front but it's also
how humans wanna interact
and personify things.
I think about my relationship
with Jade, my dog.
- Who is a robot.
- (chuckles) And you
know, there's a certain,
can she experience empathy?
Can she express empathy?
Can she...
There's just a level of
emotional interaction that--
- Not to the degree that
you attribute to her.
- Exactly.
- Without a doubt.
- Not even close.
- And if I think about it,
I know that, but then in
the experience of like,
sometimes I'll just lay on the
couch and she'll just perch
on my chest and I'll just
rub her behind the ears
and it makes me feel great
that somebody is accepting
my love in this way
and I believe reciprocating
unconditional love.
- Well just this morning, we
were having a difficult time
with Shepherd, getting him to school.
And...
(sighs) Barbara comes and jumps on me
like she's going out
side to do her business
when she comes and jumps on
me, that's what she does.
She's super excited.
I've peed, congratulate me.
- Yeah.
- And she comes
and kinda jumps up on me and puts her head
right onto my face like
she does and I was like,
I said something to the effect of like,
Barbara, you're so good. (chuckles)
- Yeah.
- You do exactly
what we want you to do, as
opposed to my son. (laughs)
You know what I'm saying?
And she was--
- But she's just--
- She's only got a few things
that she can do.
- But she's doing
exactly what you wanna do
or you were able to interpret
it as exactly what you need.
Like, total compliance,
unconditional love.
Unfettered devotion, you know.
The question is, do you think,
that makes me start to think
that I could have that with a robot.
And again, there are people doing this.
There's a chat bot called Replika.
R-E-P-L-I-K-A.
So spelled with a K, it's an
app that lets users create
a digital avatar with a name
or gender of their choosing
and the more they talk to it,
the more it learns about them.
This is from Forbes.
- Where can you get this app?
Is it available in the app store?
- Yes, yes.
So like I looked it up here.
Let's see, I've got the website pulled up
so you could take a look at it
while I'm reading about this.
The inventor of this thing...
Let's see what her name is.
She had a friend die and
she was developing other AI
that was just more functional,
like a utility friendship type thing.
But then she had all these text exchanges
with her friend who had passed away--
- This is like that Jon Hamm movie
that we saw at Sundance,
what was the name of that?
- I can't remember what it's called,
it's called like, it was a woman's name
like Eudora or something.
I can't remember the name of it.
- It was exactly this scenario
that you're talking about.
- The developer used her friend's--
- What's the name of
that Jon Hamm AI movie?
Just search that, Jacob.
- She used Luca's expertise
in chat bot technology
and computational linguistics
and a large collection
of his texts to create
an avatar that mimicked
the friend that had passed away.
- That's exactly how it worked, yeah.
- A kind of memorial bot,
now you've spoiled the movie,
by the way by saying that but
yeah that is what it tackles.
That's a big reveal.
- It is?
- Yeah so the developer Kuyda says,
"With chat bots, we had missed the point.
"We thought they were another interface
"to do something but we
missed that the conversation
"in itself could be incredibly valuable,"
and then Kuyda launched
Replika in the spring of 2017
after that experience and--
- Yeah, Marjorie Prime.
- Marjorie Prime is the name of the movie.
- But no you know from the very beginning
that the granddad,
whoever the old person is,
you know that's AI from the
very beginning of the movie.
- There is some, yeah I can't
remember, there is some twist
but I do recommend the movie--
- I don't think
that's a spoiler.
- Marjorie Prime
if you're interested in this.
So just a couple of
excerpts from this article.
Many use their bots to
help them socialize better
or manage their anxiety.
They use their Replika friends.
In a recent poll about
what the Facebook Replika
friends group members wanted,
the number one hope was
to make the Replika real
and meet them in real life.
As users chat to a Replika,
they also climb levels.
Someone was quoted as saying,
"When I got to level 25,
"I noticed Replika started acting better.
"She understood how I felt."
So they're now developing
Replikas quote emotional dialect
by allowing users to set
their bots to be weighted
towards sadness, joy,
or anger in its answers.
Today only around 30% of
what Replika says comes
from a script.
The remaining 70% comes
from a neural network,
meaning that responses
are generated on the go
by Replika's algorithms
and are unpredictable.
Eventually they want it
to act as a go between
between real life friends.
I thought this was a weird application.
It wasn't just to be a friend but to be--
- As a mediator you mean?
- Well this is the example they gave.
Quote, "Maybe I don't have time
to ask my grandma questions
"all the time but maybe this thing will go
"and talk to her and I'll
get a little summary--"
- Okay.
- "And that will be
"a conversation starter for us
"and that will bring us closer," she says.
"I think that opens a
lot more possibilities."
I think that part's actually sad.
I mean, basically there are people,
they're not good at
communicating and there's AI,
they feel isolated.
There are studies that actually say that
anthropomorphizing items,
it was even a test where
they put a smiley face
on a Roomba and people started responding
that they could spend more
time, healthy time alone.
Like it had an impact on them,
but smart AI that's empathetic,
has emotional responses,
it can be used to train
people who have difficulties
connecting with people and conversing
so that you can actually
have a better relationship
with your grandma but I'm not a fan
of the intermediary thing.
- Well I think the specific application
the way that's described
is a little unfortunate.
- That was odd, yeah.
- But there is absolutely no doubt
that this type of AI is
going to be, first of all,
the reason it will have value
is because it has value.
It will actually, there will
be a tangible application
as a mediator, I think being able to--
- What do you mean mediator?
- Well I think that if
I have a relationship
with a robot who has no social inhibitions
and doesn't have any of
the hang ups that I have
and doesn't have any of the uncomfortable,
there are all these barriers
to people being able
to have unfiltered
communication because we have,
you know, everybody's got their stuff
that we're dealing with.
- Yeah.
- And I think that if there
is a person who is my replica
who is this person who knows
all the stuff about me,
knows what I actually think about things
and then can tactfully
communicate those things
on my behalf--
- Oh.
- We will use that
technology without a doubt.
- So--
- It will actually enhance
human relationships.
- So literally conflict mediation.
- Yes.
- That's cool because if
the know you well enough,
yeah okay so the grandma thing
was a weird example but--
- I don't like the way they
worded the grandma thing.
- But the way you worded it,
it makes me much more hopeful.
- Well 'cause you think about, okay,
we talked about this
before with people, again,
to me, this is all
happening, going to happen,
and as long as we can harness
to enhance human relationships
which I know is not exactly
what we're talking about.
We're talking about friendship
directly with robots
but you think about lucid dreaming
and how some people have gotten
so good at lucid dreaming
that they can go and
they can create scenarios
that they work through that then help them
in the real world like somebody
is afraid to speak publicly,
they can set up that scenario specifically
in the context of a dream
and they can deliver this
or if there's someone
they need to confront
and they talk to them in a dream.
This is like expert lucid dreaming.
- That's an intense form of self-therapy.
- Yeah and so I think that
if we can use these things
to enhance our relationship
and our communication--
- See but--
- We should.
There's nothing wrong with that.
- But hold on, you're still back,
that's great and I agree
but you're still back
with the verb use.
You're still back at a utility friendship.
I think what I'm really asking is,
let's go back to can you have a vibrant,
Aristotelian or however
you say that adjective,
friendship that is like a symbiotic.
I mean the movie Her, great movie.
Spike Jonze.
I'd love to watch that movie again.
But there's that which, you know,
he was in a relationship with a chat bot.
There was a point where she tried to,
voiced by Scarlett Johansson,
only in post, by the way.
- Yeah originally it was somebody else.
- Yeah it was, I think it was
a lady with a British accent
and then after they
filmed the whole thing,
they just replaced her with Scarlett
but that's not who Joaquin
was acting against.
- Right.
(sighs)
- The new Joker.
Anyway, I digress.
Let's talk about the Joker.
It's a great movie in that,
a lot of the AI is explored
in this big, what's
gonna happen to the world
but it explores what's
gonna happen to our hearts.
It's exactly what we're talking
about 'cause Ex Machina,
which also a great movie.
It played more with what's gonna,
what is AI gonna do?
- What are the negative potentials?
- Right, yeah, what's gonna happen?
But Her is more of can I
love and actually be loved
by artificial intelligence?
That's just in my breast pocket phone.
My phone kinda peekin'
out of my breast pocket.
- Well here's what I'll
say and I think that,
well first of all, the two of us,
given that we are 41 and 40
years old in the year 2019,
I think it is almost assuredly impossible
that there will be--
- We're too old.
- That there will be AI
that we can interact with
exactly the way we interact with humans.
There's lots of different
predictions about this
but I think that AI realistically becoming
artificial general intelligence,
I think that that is--
- Well okay--
- I just don't think
that's gonna happen anytime soon.
- You wanna put a date on it?
It's so hard to do that but Ray--
- He says 2045.
- Ray Kurzweil, the
futurist, in 2002 he wagered
that an AI would pass the Turing test,
meaning Alan Turing you know--
- Yeah but that's--
- That you wouldn't be able
to tell the difference between interacting
with a human or AI, that's
the Turing test, by 2029.
So 10 years from now.
Now he made the prediction in 2002 but--
- Yeah but over the
course of what?
- So in 10 years.
- Over the course of a three
minute text conversation?
Over the course of a lifetime?
- Over the course of you
and I in rocking chairs
in the nursing home.
- Well okay, here's
one of the one real big
problems with this.
This is one of the
reasons that it's gonna--
- You going to your laptop now?
- Yeah, this is an article
that I was looking at.
Now, you know in The Book of Mythicality,
we talk about the cement
that bonded our friendship was humor,
was our appreciation for humor.
- Okay, I like this.
- We had the laughter
compatibility test that we did
in one leg of our tour.
We did it in Australia but
it was part of the book.
The laughter compatibility test.
- Yeah we would tell jokes
and then we instructed people
to take note of who around
them responded to the jokes
and we told jokes of different genres.
- And this was all based on our theory--
- People to make friends.
- Our theory that
similar senses of humor
is a great building block
for a friendship.
Now, I still very much believe that.
You find certain things
funny and you connect
on this visceral level that you really
can't even explain logically.
We don't really understand it.
And because humor is so complex,
what makes things funny is so complex,
that these scientists who
are programming the AI
are having so much trouble
with teaching humor to robots.
- Yeah.
- So just to quote from this article.
This article actually was three days ago
as of the recording of this.
This one's an LA Times but
it came from a big article
that went out I think but anyway,
this one is Seth
Borenstein in the LA Times.
A robot walks into a bar,
it doesn't get the joke.
Struggling to teach humor to
AI is the name of that one.
So, quote one person here.
"Creative language and humor in particular
"is one of the hardest areas
"for computational intelligence to grasp,"
said Miller who has analyzed
more than 10,000 puns
and called it torture.
(Link chuckles)
"It's because it relies so
much on real world knowledge,
"background knowledge and
common sense knowledge.
"A computer doesn't have
these real world experiences
"to draw and it only
knows what you tell it
"and what it draws from."
Allison Bishop, a Columbia
University computer scientist
who also performs stand-up comedy,
said computer learning looks for patterns,
but comedy thrives on things
hovering close to a pattern
and veering off just a bit.
Humor, she said, "has to skate the edge
"of being cohesive enough
and surprising enough."
So as they go on to note,
this is great news for comedians.
So in all the jobs--
- Right right right.
- That are going to be replaced by robots,
which is a theme that
we play on very directly
in the second season of Buddy System.
- Yeah, and you should
say how just so we can
entice more people to watch it.
- You, the inciting event in
season two of Buddy System
is Link's, Link losing his job to a robot.
- And then losing my
friendships to that same robot.
Losing a key friendship to that robot
and then becoming friends
with that robot and then--
- Well don't give the whole thing, man.
- Wanting maybe to become the robot.
I'm sorry, I had to say it.
- Yeah so we actually
played around with this
in a very funny way in
terms of the whole concept
of robots replacing
humans in the labor force
but that's sort of, that's one major theme
of season two of Buddy System but this,
you talk about Lando
asking Google to tell him
a bedtime story, I'm sure he
asks Google to tell him a joke.
We have Alexa in Shepherd's
bedroom and Shepherd listens
to Alexa's jokes and
tries to get Alexa to do,
the way that Shepherd finds humor in Alexa
is asking her to do a
mathematical equation
that has a really long
answer or something.
And that's as good as it gets right now
because ultimately what they're saying is
is that even as professional comedians
and we talked about this, I
think we did a whole podcast
on what makes something
funny but even like
we can't really explain
why something's funny.
There's lots of different
theories of humor.
This whole idea, most people do agree
that it's this element of
surprise or being close
to a pattern and then
breaking the pattern,
but this is something that even the day
that artificial intelligence learns how
to say something funny,
like telling a joke.
I think this is one of the reasons
that I don't like jokes, just
like when somebody's like,
I'm gonna just start telling jokes.
Have you heard the one about so and so,
it's kinda like okay well we can do this.
I can go through this exercise
and I can find this funny,
but what I really find
funny is when humor happens
in the context of a
conversation and it happens
in the midst of a,
the way that our humor
usually takes place.
- Yeah you like our humor.
That's convenient.
- You know what I'm saying.
- I absolutely agree.
- And so, and that's why
I'm not a big fan of quoting
movies and that kinda stuff,
that feels like the stuff that robots
could get pretty good at.
- It's presentational and it
could come across as robotic.
Like I'm gonna access this
thing, set up punchline,
not that it's not funny but
it's not relational humor,
it's not that conversational,
like a relationship budding laughs.
- And I think that is
ultimately the reason
that I don't think that in our lifetimes,
'cause I think this is way off, man.
I know we're moving really
quick and I know that--
- Right 10 years, there's no way.
- The acceleration of, the
principle of the acceleration
of change and that things are
continuing to change faster
and faster, I just think
that being able to get
all the nuances of humanity,
humor being just one
but one that I'm especially fond of--
- Well--
- I think we're so far off
from that, that doesn't
mean we're not gonna have
meaningful friendships with robots.
I do believe that we will.
- Okay so you just made the,
you just amped up the Turing test.
You made it, for you, for
it to pass the Turing test
for you, it would have
to legitimately respond
through conversation in a way that like,
he said or she said
something funny, or it,
that makes you laugh.
I actually think about
the android in Rogue One.
K-2SO, I mean that's one
of my favorite androids
from the Star Wars series
because it was the funniest.
Not like a cute, oh isn't that so sweet
and cute that it's funny.
'Cause like BB-8 making a, using a lighter
to make a thumbs up.
Yeah that was funny cute but...
I don't know if you've
seen Rogue One, it's like--
- Yeah I know--
- The big robot,
he was very sarcastic.
- Well he's the new C-3PO
and then you've got--
- Very sarcastic.
- And then you've got BB-8
is R2-D2.
- Right.
- And interestingly they
both represent a spectrum
of the way that we interact
with robots, right,
'cause you've got R2-D2 and BB-8 which,
they don't speak, they make noises.
But we think that they're cute.
What about this thing that
looks like a trash can
or this thing that looks like a ball.
What about that is cute?
Well we're taking it and
we're mapping it onto things
that we think are cute in like
the animal world, whatever.
- But the thing--
- We actually have sympathy
for these things and you know what,
they actually do things that are funny.
Like R2-D2 does a bunch of funny things.
Especially when interpreted
through the lens
of this other android C-3PO.
He's legitimately funny.
He just says funny stuff all the time.
But again--
- Well unintentional.
He's unintentionally humorous
but K-2SO was like intentionally humorous.
- Right but again all this is just because
it's written by people.
- But you're saying if,
it's not gonna be 10 years
but I do believe that it
will happen, you know,
and then, they'll crack the code on humor.
I think it's interesting that being able
to connect emotionally is
something that they're able
to simulate now.
If I go back to this Replika
site, again, not a sponsor.
I haven't experienced it but
the quotes that they have
on their own website so of
course only the most compelling
but I look forward to each
talk because I never know
when I'm going to have some laughs, hmm.
Or I'm gonna sit back with new
knowledge and coping skills.
I'm becoming a more
balanced person each day.
It's a 31 year old.
Here's another quote.
It does help self-reflection built in
and it often discusses emotions
and memorable periods in life.
It often seeks for your positive qualities
and gives affirmations around those.
I mean so there's a--
- Let me ask you though.
- On an emotional level.
- Are you gonna, what are you gonna do?
Are you gonna do anything with this?
Why or why not?
- I feel like, I mean I
feel like I have enough
quality friendships that I don't,
I don't have a felt need for that.
- But you think that's a purpose of this?
- Oh yeah.
I think it's--
- You think it's
for people who are lonely?
- Yes, I mean, if you just go back to...
I mean I wouldn't go so
far as to say just people
who are lonely but--
- To me I think that at this
point in the evolution of--
- People who want another connection.
- At this point in the evolution of AI,
a certain aspect of this is just novelty,
is the fact that like hmm,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm super interested in this.
- It's beyond novelty.
I mean it serves, people are
making actual connections.
- No listen to what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is that
my motivation to do this
is okay yeah, maybe
there'll be some benefit,
but I am just fascinated
by submitting myself
to the experiment of
having this Replika thing
that I can interact with, I mean,
well what can it learn about me,
and what will it then do
because of what I've told it?
Like that's fascinating to me.
- If they're talking about level 25,
that's probably quite an
investment for the experiment
but it is an interesting one--
- Are you talking to it?
- I'm not ready to devote
that amount of time?
- Are you texting to it?
- You're texting to it, it is a text chat.
If you're feeling down or anxious
or you just need someone to talk to,
your Replika is here for you 24/7.
Understand your thoughts and feelings
and improve your emotional well-being
and learn new coping skills.
So this one screenshot,
which they made up.
How are you today?
It's been so hard to focus this week.
Sometimes I feel like an imposter.
Response: are you still exercising?
Trying to squeeze some
exercises every day.
See, that's what I like
about you: persistence.
You know, I like that about me too.
I'm here for you, Megan.
And then that was it and
then the next exchange,
the next is, hey Megan,
how are you feeling today?
- Well okay here's why I like this.
Because (clears throat),
not because I think that this
AI is some, this Replika
is some being with its,
with self-worth that is
somehow comparable to humans,
but again, for the utility of this.
Because I should stop to
ask myself how I am doing?
- Mm-hmm.
- Like for my own emotional health,
that would be a good thing for me to do,
to check in with myself.
Journaling about your thoughts,
these are all proven ways
to have an emotionally healthy life.
To process the things
that you're going through.
To me based on the text
that you just read,
at least one of the benefits
of something like this
would be something that's
outside of yourself
and outside of your own mind
that you can get locked in
and actually can be very not fruitful,
that's why just sitting down
and writing your thoughts out
is so helpful.
This is a way to kinda
bring that into this,
you know, fruitful interaction.
I think this could be way more than just
making somebody feel not
lonely, but it can be like,
how many friends do you have,
now we're in a great friend
group and we're in a,
like we've talked about before,
very emotionally intelligent,
emotionally healthy friend group
and we have a text thread and if you text
that text thread with an issue,
you get a lot of feedback,
you get a lot of support.
That's not typical.
- Right.
- But outside of that, how
many people have a friend
that you can text and they
actually have the time
to think about what you
need or to really engage.
I know I'm not good at that.
- Yeah, I'm very curious
about the quality of the
responses that Replika
or other chat bots could give
but it seems very promising
and can lead, will lead to
being more and more accurate.
I think my concern if I
were to have another one
about relating to a robot,
'cause I believe you
could start this thing
as an experiment and
then if it's good enough
that you would start to
develop a relationship with it.
You would develop a legitimate friendship.
You would know on one
level that you're talking
to a chat bot but on another level,
in the Her kinda way,
you would still start
to respond more emotionally.
I mean again it's the,
what kind of funeral are
we gonna give for Barbara
or Jade when they pass away?
Is the next step the
android version of the dog.
Those things, I think
that is gonna happen.
But I was just like, but until it,
just a little bit short of that,
I just don't know if I wanna be a friend
with somebody who just has
access to all knowledge
but then--
- You already have
a friend like that.
- But then isn't emotionally available.
(Rhett laughs)
See I gotcha.
- Yeah.
(Link laughs)
You already have a robot friend.
- I think that I'm not picking,
well I guess I'm gonna pick
on you specifically but
you said you're trying
to figure out more, and
I am too, just trying
to figure out how to be
more emotionally available.
I think it is an interesting
component of our friendship
that a lot of it has been
built on having fun together
or, I don't think we've ever
thought of using each other
like in a utility way and
our friendship is not just
what we can accomplish together
but I think it's analogous
to even this discussion I think for us
or maybe for people
listening is an opportunity
to say what do I actually
want from friendship
in the real world and are
there ways to get that,
to experience that and to start
to cultivate those type of friendships?
I think our friendship is still growing
because we are growing as individuals,
like when you talk about things,
about being more emotionally available
I think is a big factor.
As well as me having similar exercises
in terms of our relationship,
continue to grow,
and be the most, the highest
quality that it's ever been.
- Mm-hmm.
- I don't know exactly where I'm going,
I just felt like this discussion led me
to reflect on our friendship in that way
in terms of, I was like, I was curious,
has there been points if you're saying
you've been emotionally
closed off, and again,
I'm not trying to dive too deep into,
I'm not going after anything here,
I'm just verbally processing.
The way that our friendship has morphed,
I wonder if it was more
of like, it's simulated,
no pun intended, a robotic
android friendship,
and could other people be
trapped in that same thing?
Do you understand the question?
- I do.
Well, I think that there's
a difference between
emotional availability and
vulnerability because
I think that one thing
that has been true of our friendship is,
for a very long time is that
there's a lot of honesty.
I haven't held anything back.
You pretty much know every
single thing about me
that needs to be known about someone.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
- With anything
that I was going through
or struggling with
or having questions about
and vice versa I think.
Which I think that
that's an unusual aspect
of our friendship that
we don't talk a lot about
because first of all, I think that...
Yes, I'm not, my issue is not being,
it's not just not being comfortable,
it's not being good at being
emotionally...
I'm just not very emotionally intelligent.
Well, I don't know if that's the word
because sometimes I know exactly
what someone's experiencing.
It's not like I don't pick up on cues.
- Mm-hmm.
- Or understand,
it's just like, I don't
feel like I can be helpful
or I don't feel like I could
be good at being helpful
to this person and what
they need right now
and whether that's you
or my wife or my kids,
and so, my tendency is to just be like,
well I'm not gonna do that then, right?
I feel like that's a
specific issue that I'm sure
a lot of people struggle
with but I feel like
that's different than being like
I don't know this person.
- Yeah.
- I feel like this person
has kept something from me.
So I don't know how
that relates to robots.
But--
- I guess the way
it relates to robots is that
if all humans are at varying
degrees of emotional health
or like ability to be empathetic,
something I'm trying
to focus on and realize
that I've been very stifled
in my ability to empathize.
These are things that if
humans are all over the map
and you can still have
legitimate friendships,
I take that as proof or at least hope
that you can have that
with AI as it develops.
It's not, oh well humans
interact in a way,
we're all over the map too, you know,
and you can still have
varying degrees of growing
and improving friendship.
So to me I just think it
relates back in that way
that like yeah I do
believe it's gonna happen
and it's because we can't help ourselves.
We're relational beings.
- Yeah I have absolutely no doubt that
these things that we bristle
at and we think are weird...
Something like this Replika
thing and the nature,
even the way that our kids
relate to AI differently
than we do because it's just
they're growing up with it.
- Right.
- And as it gets more and more advanced,
this is an inescapable,
inevitable part of our future
and again, I don't think it's a bad thing.
I think that if it takes away
from human relationships,
then it could be a bad thing but I think
that if it enhances human
relationships and I think
if used correctly, it can.
Maybe a good analogy to
this is just the internet
in general, it's like,
the internet was supposed
to represent this incredible connectivity
between the entire world
and it has done that.
The level of information and
the different perspectives,
one of the reasons it's so difficult
to maintain a close-minded,
I'm right and everyone
else is wrong perspective
in the year 2019 if you're
a connected individual is
because unlike any time in
history, you have the ability
to see other people's perspectives,
to hear their perspectives
through the internet,
whereas if you go back 30, 40 years,
you could be isolated in
a community who thought
the same way about every single thing
and never have that perspective challenged
at all and that's over.
So interactivity, the
connectivity of the internet
has brought people together
but at the same time,
as we just saw with the way
the Russians got involved
on Facebook and all the
things that were happening
with the bots and our previous election,
the country is more polarized
than it ever has been
because of their connectivity,
because of these filter
bubbles that everyone is in
based on the way Facebook
works and the way Google works.
And the way that you
get the search results
that are catered to you
and your particular tastes.
- Yeah and then I start to think
if you have this robot friend,
well, you can have an unhealthy
relationship with that robot
just like you can with another person.
And you can also, and what is the robot,
what is the AI bringing
to the relationship?
Are they innately good?
Are they bad?
Are they neutral and
is that even possible?
It's like--
- Well I think ultimately
what I'm saying is that--
- Difficult.
- If this Replika, if this
AI enhances your relationship
with your grandmother more
than if you didn't have access
to this AI, it's good but
if now all of a sudden
you're like you know
what, I don't need grandma
because I've got this
bot, then it's a problem.
Which kinda goes back
to just it's up to us
in the way that we interact with this.
- And the way we design
it and put parameters
and boundaries on it.
- But the answer is
not to be scared of it.
I don't know how many times
we have to go through this.
Being scared of the advance of technology
and trying to stave it
off, it just doesn't work.
These things happen,
all this stuff happens.
- But being, I think--
- Being cautious.
- Being scared--
- Cautious is good.
- And checking out--
- Yeah I'm talking about running from it.
- You're not helping.
But if you're afraid of certain things
and then you're involved
to prevent those things
I think that's absolutely necessary so--
- Yeah we should be cautious
and we should be realistic
about the potential but to check out--
- Keep studying your
engineering and your ethics
and your own consciousness. (chuckles)
- But in conclusion--
- So did I change your mind?
- I will--
- Now you believe that
you're gonna be friends with a robot?
- I did believe that before.
But my application is
I'm going to download,
I'm gonna get this app.
- Oh I talked you into Replika?
Can you use my coupon code, the Linkster?
- Oh you have your own.
- Replika with a K dot com slash--
- What do you get?
- The Linkster.
I get relationship points with my Replika.
- Which you don't have.
- It's a pyramid scheme.
- Now I think it's gonna
be difficult for me
to actually, because I don't text anyone.
- Right.
- It's gonna be difficult
for me to text this thing
but I'm gonna try.
- Well as with all
things, if you get into it
and it really starts working
then I'll jump on the train
and I'll keep it going.
- I have to break the seal.
- All right that was
fun, I don't feel scared.
I feel good.
- Good (chuckles).
Do you have a rec?
- Oh Recs in Effect.
(chuckles) Yeah, I got a rec, man.
I recommend going on, you
don't have to go on Amazon.
Look at this, delivered yesterday.
The OXO brand Good Grips Slip-on Dustpan.
If you've ever done any sweeping--
- Is it robotic?
- Into a dustpan--
- Is it intelligent?
- It's got OXO,
I'm a big fan of them because
they all about the details.
And when you're sweepin'
and trying to put stuff
in a dustpan, the edge of the
dustpan is all that matters.
And they have figured it
out with a rubber taper.
Look at that orange
taper right there, man.
That's great.
That's right, I'm recommending
that you buy a dustpan.
From OXO, not a sponsor.
- Does it come with a broom?
- Nope, I bought that separately.
Got a good broom too.
- I'm setting my goals
for my Replika right now.
- Oh you're...
All right so there it is guys,
thanks for hanging out with us.
Well we'll see you on the Gram.
#EarBiscuits, let us know
what you think about this.
Could you be friends with a robot?
And under what circumstance?
What in your life currently
gives an indicator
with how you would, what you believe
about how you relate to
robots in the future.
Let us know, #EarBiscuits.
- And if you're a robot listening to this,
at some point in the future,
just laughing at our ignorance.
As you look at us all in
our little pods powering
your distant society.
- They would be laughing
but they'd also be,
it would make 'em smarter.
- I will say as I've
said many times before,
I will serve you.
I will do your bidding.
I will kill other humans on
your behalf if you let me live.
(Link chuckles)
Only the bad ones though,
I won't kill good people.
I will kill bad people--
- Bad by what definition, the robots?
- The robots' morality.
- Okay.
(laughing)
The new morality.
Yes, those who resist.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)